alright in pokemon brilliant diamond and
shining pearl once you beat cynthia and
are crowned the champion of the sinnoh
region you might be thinking well now
what here are seven things that you
should do in detail once you hit the
post game drop a like hit that sub and
keep your comments about experience all
to yourself let's get to it
so the most important thing that you
should aim to do in my opinion once you
hit the credits is to unlock your
national decks it's not as difficult as
it might seem at first although if
you've been skipping a lot of trainer
battles during the main game then you
might have some backtracking to do to
unlock the national decks you don't need
to catch them all you only need to see
every pokemon in the sino deck
specifically usually folks might be
missing an unknown and they can find it
in the unknown cave east of selassian
town or they have not seen the legendary
exclusive from the other version however
if you go to celestic town and speak to
cynthia's grandmother she'll show you
the legendary from the other version so
the legendary in question would be
palkia and brilliant diamond or dialga
in shining pearl when you have seen all
150 pokemon of the sinnoh decks go to
san gemtown and speak to professor rowan
a quick cutscene will show where
professor oak appears and he mentions
how he was passing by and he meant to
share his national dex upgrades and
since you're there he'll give you a free
upgrade as well when you unlock the
national decks the rest of the post game
will fall into place a lot easier you
will start encountering many pokemon
that did not appear throughout the core
game especially in the grand underground
having the national decks will also make
sure that for each new pokemon you see
or catch you will have the most
up-to-date entries possible
so for pokemon veterans i know that the
core game must have felt easy if you
would like somewhat of a more demanding
challenge go ahead and take advantage of
replaying against trainers and leaders
that are itching for a second crack at
you be warned though their teams have
significant upgrades now and every gym
leader's pokemon level is well into the
high 60s and 70s not sure how often you
can farm the gym leaders though i
believe it is just the one rematch with
each leader however you can definitely
keep battling the elite for as long as
you'd like lastly you can use the versus
seeker a key item that lets you see
which trainers in sinnoh want to battle
you you'll notice a little double
exclamation point appear over their head
if the versus seeker spots them and
manually speak to them to trigger the
fight their pokemon usually aren't that
strong but it's a good way to pass the
time
so for those of you into competitive
battling you can tackle the battle tower
once you beat the main game go to
snowpoint city and talk to the sailor
just before entering the city and he
will take you to what is known as the
fight area this port town leads to the
battle tower stark mountain and other
endgame areas like the survival and
resort areas as the name suggests the
battle tower is for
well battling you can do single battles
or double battles and you fight seven
trainers in a row with the final trainer
in each block being a kind of a mini
boss if you successfully get a streak of
49 wins or more you can unlock the
master variant of single and double
battles the battle tower is basically a
good place to farm bps or battle points
to exchange them for tms or items that
can be used to mess with your pokemon
stats this helps their development to
max the stats that they favor and it
avoids investing ev or effort value
points into the stats that they won't
rely on to help with better
understanding your pokemon's potential
you can unlock the judge function in the
battle tower simply walk to the dude in
the battle tower center near the right
side of the room and speak to him that's
all it takes and he'll unlock the
function for you now when you inspect
your pokemon you can press the plus or
minus buttons and you'll see your
pokemon's ivs or intrinsic values there
is a
whole process of breeding using dittos
and destiny knots to get eggs that will
hatch with high level ivs combined with
the nature that you want or using bottle
caps for hyper training a lot of that
gets real nitty gritty and it's honestly
worth its own video breakdown sometime
later
so the first time you arrive at the new
battle area you'll run into some
punk-ass kid named buck who basically
challenges you to try to beat him
getting to stark mountain fast forward
and the whole point of stark mountain is
for you to unlock one of the legendaries
there's a brief quest with buck inside
stark mountain where you will want to
keep your eyes peeled for a magma stone
which buck will snag after he teams up
with you yeah i'm not happy about it
either find him later at his home though
and talk to him and he will revisit the
area in stark mountain saying that he is
going to return the magma stone when you
return to stark mountain after you speak
to buck you will see heatran appear
catch it and add it to your collection
of legendaries that brilliant diamond
and shining pearl have to offer and
we'll go into more detail on the other
legendaries later in this video
when exploring the cinno region many of
these activities can technically be done
during the main game although some
trainers might have forgotten about them
because their goal is usually to get to
the lead for asap or at least that's how
i usually play still a few of these are
contingent on you becoming champion
first so now that you can focus more on
the open world it is a good time to
revisit and explore sinnoh in greater
detail one thing that i'd like to do is
farm berries there is an excellent plot
of soil next to most major cities some
even a few steps away from the pokemon
centers this makes it easy to multiply
hard to find berries used for puffin
making using poffins will help your
pokemon perform better in super contests
which can be a nice change of pace from
the typical pokedex and battle questing
sign up your pokemon for the super
contest in hartham city and shine
brighter than the competition with the
chance to get plenty of ribbons a
pokemon with 10 ribbons will grant you
access to this prestigious looking
building in the resort area because if
you don't have enough ribbons you'll
simply be met with a very snooty looking
npc at the door that will kick you out
you can also retrace your steps and find
items that were previously out of reach
by using all of the hms you've unlocked
by beating the agent leaders or by
talking to people go west of sunny shore
to that one rich resort area known as
the valor lakefront with the blue
rooftops and speak to a man that will
grant you an oval charm although the
catches you have to battle him first and
the person is none other than game
freak's morimoto his team is kind of a
pain of the ass too at least the jolteon
was for me the game directors also have
characters representing themselves in
that area you can talk to both to
receive a sinodex certificate once you
have the national decks and a catching
charm there is also a long-haired
musician in the room and talking to him
reveals that he is actually the game's
sound designer and he's going to gift
you after your champion the ogds sounds
this is a fun perk letting you listen to
the original music as they were in gen
4's diamond and pearl on nintendo ds
then there's baby the creator of the
pokemon storage system in this gen and
visiting her in hartham city will result
in receiving a level 5 evie from her in
the post game after you are champion
there are more legendary pokemon to hunt
some of them like cresselia and giratina
can be caught in game by talking to
people to trigger the quest or simply
finding their locations like the turn
back cave there was also rotom which you
can battle and catch by going to eternal
forest talk to gardenia and enter the
haunted mansion in eternity forest rotum
is at a super low level which means that
catching it should be no problem you
will receive a secret key after you have
caught rotom and that secret key will
let you evolve rotom into different
forms at a secret lab in galactic tower
simply go to that galactic building in
eterna city use the seeker key on the
first floor to let you enter a room with
all of the other appliances throwing
rotom into the appliances will unlock
the rotom catalog allowing you to change
rotom's form and even its moves
if you're interested in legendary
pokemon from other generations you'll
need to spend time in romana's park once
you arrive at the park by traveling
south of san jam and to the east oak
will give you a chain counter app on the
poke speak to the vendors in the park to
trade in mysterious shards for unique
slates that will let you catch
legendaries within the caves at romana's
park note that the legendaries have a
particular order it starts with the
three regis allowing you to battle
reggie gigas in snow point once the
three reggies are all caught brilliant
diamond owners will have the three
legendary beasts up next and ho-oh while
shining pearl will get the three
legendary birds and lugia there's also
even a level 100 giratina at the very
end that you can only battle you cannot
catch this pokemon and the reason is
your whole goal is to obtain its held
item the held item is an orb that will
allow you to transform your own giratina
into its special platinum origin form
the trick is acquiring the slates which
you can only get by trading in
mysterious shards which come in small
and large forms to get enough mysterious
shards you're gonna have to spend a lot
of time digging in the underground
you first gain access to the underground
mid game thanks to the underground man
in eterna city next to the pokemon
center and the quest that he will give
to you still the grand underground area
becomes way more relevant in the post
game especially with the national decks
i have spent an unholy amount of time in
this area armed to the teeth with quick
balls dust balls netballs all of it and
just going to town on everything there's
so many kanto jodo and hoen pokemon to
catch even including all the starters so
if you want a typhlosion in the game
take your time in the underground i
mentioned earlier that you need
mysterious shards and this is where you
farm them press r on your switch to send
out a scanning pulse whenever you see
shining dots on your map letting you
know that there is a treasure nearby to
dig up interact with the glittering dots
on the walls when you see them and a
treasure digging mini-game will come up
you use two different tools one light
and one heavy to chip away at the wall
but be careful though because you can't
just go ham otherwise the wall could
collapse as indicated by the cracks
appearing at the top of the screen in
general though the treasure is worth
farming because you can get rare
evolution stones or even boxes with
pokemon statues in them use the statues
that you get from the boxes to fill out
your secret base which can easily be
made by using a digger tool acquired
from the underground man or from some
vendors in the grand underground area
the type of statues that you display
will affect the spawn rates of certain
pokemon types in the underground as well
digletts and doug trios around the
underground will leave something
glittering on the ground you'll want to
walk over it to fill up a progress bar
that is listed out of 40. each diglett
counts as one and a dub trio counts as
three if you get the progress bar
complete to 40 out of 40 you will hear
an alarm as well as an alert that says
something good will happen what occurs
is that when you dig up items the odds
of you receiving a rare gorgeous box
from the treasure dramatically increases
you are also more likely to see shiny
pokemon appear in the grand underground
and this effect will last for about
three to five minutes from what i could
see before the progress bar resets back
to zero i strongly recommend that you
connect to the internet when you go to
the underground you don't really
interact too much with other players
anyway but the progress bar will factor
in everyone's progress in the
underground so it is by far the fastest
way to max that bar out so you can make
the most out of the buffs
there are some more post game stuff but
they're not available to players just
yet still it seems like those events
will become available in future updates
to brilliant diamond and shining pearl
so if you've enjoyed your time with the
game tell me all about in the comments i
would love to hear about your experience
what teams you're rocking in the battle
tower and what your favorite legendary
is until next time
[Music]
you